hi everyone i'm vanessa prodomo of
bloomberg quick take
the big ten is back they announced today
that college football will be played
this year
to break down the news i'm joined by
college football expert nicole auerbach
of the athletic
nicole thanks for joining me absolutely
so break down the news for me today it
was busy
busy day for you i'm sure they announced
one month ago
they postponed the season and now here
we are how did we get here
yeah it's been a crazy uh 40 day period
of time here that's going back to when
they announced like their
revised fall schedule um then six days
later postponed the season indefinitely
and then now we're here 36 days later
saying that they are going to play in
the fall after all
with an october 23rd 24th start date
um it's kind of crazy because as as
everyone who's kind of loosely followed
sports understands you know there has
been
a lot of anger about the big ten's
decision to postpone
so you had parents organizing protests
justin fields the quarterback at ohio
state
he had started a petition to get the big
ten to reverse this decision
there was a lawsuit from nebraska
players coaches
like ryan day at ohio state james
franklin at penn state
scott frost at nebraska really banging
the drums saying
we can play let us play other people are
playing
so that was the backdrop you had here
and then the league found out that they
could
have rapid daily antigen testing so that
changes the equation from a medical
standpoint and gets to the point where
university presidents were coming to a
unanimous decision
to restart the season in october so we
have the daily testing that really made
them feel comfortable what are the other
protocols they have going on that is
going to make this
as safe as possible for the students
yeah now
just to harp on that daily testing
element for a second um
what it does is it ensures that every
athlete that steps on
that field for practice or a competition
has tested negative for covid
right then so what that means is you're
not going to be having someone do a pcr
test wait a few days to get the result
and perhaps unknowingly spread
the virus within their own team or to an
opponent who may be living somewhere
else in the country
so cutting down on that and the contact
tracing required
is a huge deal and that's why people
refer to these daily tests as
as game changers so you have that part
of the puzzle as well and then there's
also
very specific detailed protocols a
player that tests positive is not
available to return competition for 21
days which is longer than
the other leagues that are playing right
now because they're going to go through
a series of cardiac screening
um to address concerns related to
myocarditis and other heart
inflammations
so you have a couple of different things
happening here as well
as restrictions about okay if you're at
a certain positivity rate
on your roster or in your community
you're not
able to play and it would trigger a
shutdown so there's very specific
thresholds
um from a health and safety standpoint
that these teams are going to have to
meet on a weekly basis
in order to play games so it's very very
detailed and it answers a lot of those
questions that the presidents had
four weeks ago and like you said some
people were very angry with the big
ten's decision to not play
do you think they should have waited it
out like the other conferences
do you think now that we have these new
things in place
that it was kind of a bad call on their
part or do you think they were really
just trying to do what they thought was
best for athletes
i mean i think they thought that they
were doing what's best for their
athletes and these are university
presidents
who have to make decisions about the
entire campus right like they're dealing
with stuff beyond just sports
and they don't want to have something
that's going to put the entire community
the state the city everyone at risk just
to play football games right so you had
11 presidents that five weeks ago
decided to postpone the season
indefinitely
and then received new medical
information and again cardiac screening
and ways to address the heart
inflammation problem
um you know in some of those long-term
potential health risks as well
so all of that changes the equation
that's kind of how i've been phrasing it
it changes the equation of how you feel
comfortable allowing something to move
forward
or not um and and i think that what you
could have done
absolutely five weeks ago is delay the
start of the season
buy time see if there are advances in
daily rapid testing which is what some
of these other
leagues did do the sec hasn't started
yet
and their decision to postpone to
september 26th looks smarter and smarter
in retrospect because it buys you time
for medical advancements and to see
how other people are doing this on other
campuses
right and just like that you said um to
see how other people are doing it do you
think
the pressure from other people playing
or at least having plans to play
also pushed them forward to this
decision well
it's an interesting question because i i
think you know obviously this doesn't
happen without the medical advances and
the
procurement of the daily rapid testing
but i think you could
absolutely i don't think we get to this
point where it's such a hot topic if you
don't have that public pressure and your
own coaches
applying that pressure constantly and
part of their refrain including ryan day
at ohio state earlier
last week was hey other people are
playing notre dame is playing
um so why is it safe enough for them but
it's not safe enough
for us and so i think you know you also
have high school sports
taking place in in a lot of these states
as well so
um it absolutely is an important
backdrop and a factor but you know
northwestern's president morton shapiro
he was on a zoom call with us
earlier in the day and you know he was
asked basically that exact question and
he said that that for him was not the
decision he is someone who voted
to postpone five weeks ago he said the
medical advice
for the advisors for the conference were
split five weeks ago and they were
unanimous and comfortable now
and that's what changed his decision but
it'd be foolish to pretend that that
backdrop
you know didn't come into play here
right for sure
and talking about the competition aspect
of it
now the big ten is back what does it
look like for the college football
playoffs
yeah i mean i i they're gonna have a
chance the the big ten champion is going
to have a chance to make the college
football playoff because
all you really need in a weird year like
this where we don't know how many games
you know alabama's going to play or
oklahoma's going to play because of you
know contact tracing and these
postponements that have already happened
we've already had over a dozen
in college football so far um you just
need to get in the ballpark
and and this will allow the big ten
champion there's there's no built-in
idle weeks because
of the time crunch here but it's an
eight plus one so you have eight regular
season games and then a conference
championship
um and that will put them in the
ballpark as teams that are playing 10
games in a conference championship
um will have so this is going to be a
huge challenge for the college football
playoff
selection committee because they all
really it's already a tough
job but it's going to be more subjective
and challenging than ever before
when you're going to have teams that are
likely not going to be playing the same
amount of games they're also going to be
playing different types of schedules but
they're also probably not playing
just fundamentally the same amount of
games and
also since they're starting so much
later than everyone everybody knows you
know
game time is so important and
getting into the rhythm of that so do
you think that having this start
so later in the season is also going to
help like hurt them in the way that
maybe
their play won't be as strong i actually
think it might be the opposite because
we've seen a lot of sloppy play
come out in the first couple weeks of
the season and it makes total sense
because if you think about it
these athletes didn't have spring
football they all went home for three
months tried to stay in shape but
weren't
you know using their state of the art
strength and conditioning programs that
they're used to
and then they came back and even their
fall pre-season camp
was truncated so we've seen especially
special teams has been a mess people you
know haven't implemented different types
of defenses
um or more of the more of the playbook
offensively so
this will give them more time to ramp up
it's also a league that didn't actually
get to the point of having
you know full contact practices they
actually shut down
prior to preseason camp so they do need
this month plus to ramp up from
just a physical safety standpoint so
that they are ready for full contact
full speed when games start
but also they will have some more time
to have more of a traditional
training camp um which could end up
helping them because as we've seen
some of these other programs are a
little bit rusty for sure
and now nicole can you tell me what's
going on with the pac-12
you know they're expected to you know
maybe make an announcement
but they do have some uh complications
can you describe to us what's going on
with that
yeah i think all eyes now go to the
pac-12 because
now we're back up to four of the five
power five leagues playing in the fall
in the traditional time period
um and and i think that you know the
pac-12
is not expected to like immediately
follow the big ten's decision
although the pac-12 did procure daily
rapid antigen testing as well it will be
on their campuses
by the end of september but the
circumstances are totally different
all of the schools in california and
oregon face severe restrictions from
their states
so they can't practice they couldn't
have a contact practice right now
and that's six members of your
conference um so you actually had usc
players write a letter to
governor gavin newsom uh last night
tuesday night
asking basically to roll back some of
those restrictions so they can practice
obviously there's pro sports happening
in california
um but they're they're granted certain
exemptions right now these college
programs can't practice
can't get in the weight room so that is
a huge limiting factor understandably so
you know even with the testing you know
even with momentum people feeling like
with cardiac screening they feel more
comfortable with the heart inflammation
and some of those other long-term risks
they just physically
can't practice and that's when we talk
about how this is the virus is different
in different parts of the country it's
because different states have different
restrictions in place
based on those local outbreaks so that's
absolutely a factor when you think about
the pac-12 and whether or not this
adjusts their timeline at all
and what kind of pressure do you think
the the usc players were putting
on uh the governor there do you think
that will really change anything or do
you think there's bigger things that
they really have to
focus on well you know i would have said
that there's bigger things for
politicians to focus on about the big
ten too and the president has been
tweeting about it right
so um i i do think that you know it's
certainly an interesting
um it's an interesting development um
and again they're not even asking to
necessarily be able to play games
they're just asking
to reduce some of the restrictions so
they can practice they can work out they
can ramp up for whenever they are able
to play
um and it's particularly interesting
because this is a governor who has been
you know at the forefront of athlete
rights when it comes to name image and
likeness
this is also a conference that had you
know the we are united
players movement um about health and
safety and about economic rights for
these athletes
um so i kind of wonder you know all of
that coming together i am very curious
to see how gavin newsom responds
if it's pro athletes and this is what
they want to do
or if it's pro safety because again he's
been very restrictive
you know from a state standpoint about
what regular people can do
to try to get control of this pandemic i
would love to touch on that
uh campaign that they did put out do you
think that in any way
stops them from trying to play this
season or do you think that's something
that's in the back
of the president's minds before they
really go ahead with a plan
you know it's an interesting question
because it was so
late it was it was like almost an 11th
hour effort because it happened
basically right as the league was
shutting down and making those decisions
for the health and safety reasons and a
lot of those reasons and the demands
from those pac-12 players
were about health and safety concerns so
to me
i think if you address those you don't
have that issue
as much you also in between now and then
you've had the ncaa said
any player can opt out for health
reasons
this year and have their scholarship
next year you've had the ncaa rule that
no matter how many games are played
you know everyone's getting a free year
of eligibility you're not hurting
harming anything so so to me um
you know some of those those major
concerns were addressed and i think
also you had um you had these athletes
who were even part of the movement
you know when they would get asked you
know are you willing to opt out are you
willing to
to not play and strike and they weren't
necessarily sure i think you know you
talked to
some of the organizers some of them were
absolutely willing not to play
and the other ones were waiting to see
if some of those conditions improved so
um
so you know it was an interesting you
know again threat of a boycott but it
was also
again kind of we never got to the point
where it's fully formed and we got to
see like
just how many players would have been
involved so i do think with some health
and safety concerns addressed
it's a different animal absolutely
nicole thanks so much for joining me and
shedding some light on these
really busy days that we've been having
in college football we'll keep an eye on
the pac-12
and i'm sure a lot of people are looking
forward to seeing the big ten this year
absolutely anytime thanks for joining us
guys